i've just always got up in the morning
and wanted to fill the day with as much
fun as possible you know
i think it's funny life
it's amusing
because we take everything so seriously
we care about everything passionately we
have fights wars worry about little
things
and then we die but there's nothing it
was pointless we returned to the stars
so i always thought i want to fill my
days with fun
well i think life is precious because
you can't watch it again but once you
realize you're not going to be around
forever i think that's what makes life
so magical
one day you'll eat your last meal
smell your last flower hug your friend
for the very last time you might not
know it's the last time so that's why
you should do everything you love with
passion you know
treasure the few years you've got
because
that's all there is
you have ruminated on death you've got a
long way to go yet but um
what will death be like when it comes
well the best thing about death is
you won't know about it
it's like being stupid it's only painful
for others so i'm not bothered by it we
we do ponder the universe not always
come back to us it always comes back to
us you know why are we here we just are
the chance of us being born is 400
trillion to one and
there's loads of reasons why you can say
we're here um
and uh
it's it's more what you do with it it's
to to eat and drink and make friends and
have fun make people laugh
oh there's no better privilege
when uh
you're more unhappy than happy um
there's something wrong and you've got
to do something about it parties don't
last forever nor should they people
would hate to live forever they'd they'd
hate it
you know growing up we were poor and
working class my dad was a labourer we
lived in a
a council estate my mum was a housewife
but i didn't really know everyone was in
the same boat so i didn't i didn't know
i was poor i didn't know i was working
class until i got to university and
everyone spoke like the queen i didn't
know what it was really
bob dylan
said a man
can consider himself a success
if he gets up in the morning goes to bed
at night and in between does exactly
what he wants
and i've always done that i've always
done that
i've never worried
when i was trying to be a pop star and
no money i never moaned about i never
borrowed money it was it was my lot i
chose to do that
and then
i've always done
things the way i wanted it i've never
craved money i've never been proud of
money per se in fact the first few years
of getting a a newfound wealth i felt
guilty about it and i still feel a
little bit guilty because there was a
nobility in
in poverty really
and and so i've always thought that
if i'm going to be rich and famous then
i've got to be proud of how i made my
money and how i got my fame and
money making money i've never understood
it you know i've never understood it i
don't play those games i don't play them
i don't try and make more money i never
i've never tried to make money feared
fame when i when i first started
doing this and it came i came to it
late and almost accidentally and
i suppose organically i got a little
radio job when i was about 37 38 after
i'd worked in an office for 10 years and
then i started popping up and then it
sort of grew from now got a little bit
on a
thing called the 11 o'clock show then
the office came i knew if i was
you know a famous actor or comedian that
i'd be
you know recognized but i want to know
that was an upshot of it i wasn't doing
it to be famous and i sort of feared it
i didn't sign that contract you know
with the devil make me famous you can go
through my bins
and do you know what i mean right and i
sort of worried i think i worried about
it because i thought oh they say
horrible things about famous people and
you don't you don't want to have
horrible things said about you it
happens all the time
twitter and which is like reading every
toilet war in the world at once right
and you should you shouldn't know those
things about you you know you shouldn't
hear things about you in normal life you
shouldn't be famous it's odd to be
famous and i sort of feared that and for
the first few years i thought oh that's
not fair because i thought reputation is
everything and i realize it's not
reputation is what strangers think of
you right and who you really are is what
your friends and family think of you and
they stay forever so i just don't care
now it's also subjective that the only
real thing is what you what you do with
it you know people don't respect facts
anymore everyone knows my opinion is
worth as much as your opinion but now
there's this myth that my opinion is
worth as much as you're a fact which
just isn't true and it's going to send
us back into the dark ages just because
you're offended doesn't mean you're
right
i was already a comedian
before i sort of decided i'd become a
comedian it just sort of happened i went
on the radio show and i was meant to be
the head of speech i had a normal job i
worked in an office for 10 years which
is what i based the office on and then i
got a job at a radio station and i was
meant to go in and sort of be writing
little things for the djs and because
i'm so lazy i thought i'll just do this
myself so i went in i popped up i did
funny things the bosses said listen
you're rubbish at your real job so just
do that
and and it grew and i became like the
the comedy turn on xfm got discovered by
channel 4 and all that
nothing gives me an adrenaline rush like
coming up with an idea honestly i i i
can't sleep and if i think of it before
i go to bed i've got a work over so i
don't forget it when i i wake up and
that's a that's a lovely thing to wake
up to oh that idea right you know and it
doesn't get any better than when it's in
your head really it
and then you just gotta ruin it as
little as possible
and honestly when i when i first started
this i thought i was a writer right um
and i probably only
uh directed because i realized that i
could protect the writing and then i
produced to protect the directing it's
all to protect the idea everything and i
i play that guy because i know how to do
that guy in my head it's trying to
realize
the vision
you're not afraid of dividing opinion
you're not afraid of you know some
people saying i disagree with you and
some people say i agree with you if
everyone's agreeing with you
you're in an echo chamber you've just
chosen your people to speak to i mean
the important thing
for me
is no one has to laugh i in fact i
embraced the gasps as much as the laughs
because that means they were listening
an offense is good a fence makes people
think it makes them come up with another
argument i'm just tired of people saying
i'm offended i want to say so what that
just means you're just telling me your
feelings i'm never trying to
um offend i think i got that reputation
um from the golden globes maybe where i
gently ribbed some of the richest most
privileged beautiful people in the world
a joke about a bad thing isn't the same
as the bad thing it's not even
necessarily condoning the bad thing it
could be auntie the bad thing it could
be viled in irony or satirical or
whatever but i think people have to you
know look look at what a joke is what
the real target is i'd only say i'm
controversial because
i talk about controversial subject it's
funny because
comedians always get asked is there
anything you wouldn't joke about but
journalists don't get asked is there
anything you wouldn't write about and
all we're doing is discussing a subject
but very quickly and hopefully with a
punchline comedy comes from a good or a
bad place and twitter was the one that
sort of started
popularity being more important than
being right
you know and people picked up symptoms
of that in all walks of life because
it's all about likes retweets blocks
someone doesn't agree with you so you
create your own echo chamber same as
facebook
how arrogant are you to think that you
deserve to go through life with no one
ever saying anything that you don't
agree with or like uh
people mistake sometimes demanding
equality right by not being part of
humor yeah it's actually demanding um
privilege i want people to stop saying
that joke's offensive yeah i wanted to
start saying i found it offensive
because you've got to own the emotion
because that's all it is you're just
telling me how you feel about it yeah